but it was fireworks and then it just
didn't stop and I'm like Debbie that's
how fire works and then people started
running running and we asked what was
going on and they said it was a shooter
and and then we realized it was it
sounded like machine guns honestly at
the start we all thought that it was
probably like an electronic thing and
malfunction or stuff feedback or whatnot
never it was kind of I'm like hey it's
okay everybody's alright and then all of
a sudden people started dropping
everyone who I thought you know was has
passed on they have an article of my
clothing covering their eyes Kevin
Carter their body
everyone who I saw breathing I hope man
the shots just kept coming and so we
were going down and when we got down
there was a man that was shot right
there they were trying to take him out
he was all bloody and he was unconscious
59 dead 527 injured those are some of
the eyewitnesses at last night's
massacre in Las Vegas joining us now
Jennifer Byrne and Taylor Benja and they
were both witnessed the shooting last
night Jennifer let's start with you tell
us where you were tell us what happened
tell us what you saw right we were
actually on a platform the left at the
stage the night before we were right up
front by the railing where all the
bullets were ricocheting this night we
just didn't feel like being
claustrophobic so we made a last-minute
decision to go to the Malibu ten and go
up on a platform that was about 15 feet
high so we really didn't know it was
going on until near the end we thought
it was fireworks we thought was a
helicopter first time it went the second
time we thought it was sound problem
when the lights went off and then we saw
people running the third time and people
told us get down and we got down and we
the bullets are going over our head and
someone said just run and we jumped off
the side of the platform so it's got to
be terrifying the moment you realize
what's actually happening here Taylor
tell us your story I was on the the
right side of the stage
probably just opposite of her and you
know at first like a lot of people say
it's not like fireworks but that soon
erupted into a lot more than that and I
started to realize something went wrong
as soon as the you know the artist ran
backstage and the lights turned on there
was a gentleman about 5 feet away from
me to my left side with a bullet wound
right under his chin and oh man I could
see in his face he he wasn't there
anymore and you know that was that was
one of many faces and unfortunately you
know a lot of people didn't make it out
and a lot of people didn't know what to
do you mean at the time can I do you
mean he literally had gotten hit in the
chin in the face yeah he got hit right
under here and there was another
gentleman I didn't see him but my sister
Dave who was hitting the temple
unfortunately but these people were feet
away from us and I can't imagine what
would have happened had I brought my
brother because he was supposed to go
with us or had you know the either me or
my sister you know be be two feet to the
left or right you know wouldn't I where
we show these images and these still
pictures the field clears and then you
saw people racing out in the middle to
help all of those people that were
injured maybe fatally they didn't know
when they were helping them did you also
see that part going on I saw a lot of
people helping in fact when I ran into
the back parking lot and made it to the
the dirt part of it a gentleman and a
pickup truck
allowed me and my sister to get in the
back of his truck with someone who was
shot in the chest and you know we got in
that car and my sister and I we jumped
out and he just kept going but we got to
our car and went about southbound to the
McCarran Airport area because as far as
we knew there was multiple shooters for
how many rounds were going off you just
hear it it's so it's chilling is beyond
chilling Jennifer when you finally
recognize what what actually happened
here and you looked out you saw what was
happening in people scattering what did
you see
we just ran I was with two other girls
we lost each other immediately we all
went in three different directions one
friend ended up hiding in a dumpster
McCarron by the tarmac another one
gotten in an SUV with also three victims
I just ran to the left but the farther
away through back roads away from the
strip and the farther I ran it the
bullets got the gunfire got louder and
it felt like it was getting closer like
they were right behind you which led us
if we think there were multiple shooters
it sounded like there was just they were
super close behind us and the farther
you ran the closer they got many lives
were changing the wreckage saying of
bullets mm-hmm
Jennifer Taylor thanks for sharing your
story with our audience sorry you'll
both had to go through that and our
thoughts and prayers obviously with the
families as I'm sure many parents now
with their kids and hospitals and they
don't know the outcome of this yet